[Musik]
einen guten Abend ihr schafft das schon
viele Flüchtlinge und kein Plan das ist
unser Thema heute und damit ein
herzliches Willkommen über eine Million
Menschen sind im letzten Jahr aus der
Ukraine zu uns geflohen und rund 240.000
aus aller Welt das sind mehr als im Jahr
2015 es fehlen Wohnraum Schul- und
Kitaplätze Arbeitsplätze und vieles mehr
die Bundesregierung hört erst jetzt auf
die Hilferufe aus den Kommunen viele
Flüchtlinge würden sich auch gerne
selbst helfen warum es selbst für die
gut ausgebildeten unter ihnen so schwer
ist eine Arbeit zu finden auch darüber
müssen wir reden mit diesen Gästen
die Ministerpräsidentin von
Rheinland-Pfalz Malu Dreyer
Hendrik wüst der Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen der Tübinger
Oberbürgermeister Boris Palma
die ukrainische Ärztin Hanna Stoja
Helene bubbrowski von der FAZ und der
Landrat von Opal Timo Schomann
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
[Musik]
und die begrüßt alle noch mal sehr
herzlich 1,1 Millionen Menschen sind aus
der Ukraine nach Deutschland geflohen
fast 1,1 Millionen geflüchtete seit
Kriegsbeginn Deutschland hat mehr
Ukraine aufgenommen als Polen
für sie gilt Schutz ohne Asylantrag auch
können ukrainische Flüchtlinge sofort
arbeiten
im Februar 2023 waren bei den Jobcentern
480.000 Ukraine registriert Ende 2022
hatten 120.000 Ukraine einen
sozialversicherungspflichtigen Job
Länder und Kommunen läuten die
Alarmglocke
über eine Million aus der Ukraine plus
widersteigende Asylbewerber Zahlen
überfordern
das fehlt an Wohnraum ob wir das ein
weiteres Jahr schaffen bei dem
quantitativen Zuwachs den wir haben das
kann man heute sicherlich nicht
prognostizieren wir wenden im Jahr rund
800 Millionen Euro für die Bewältigung
der Flüchtlingssituation auf davon
kommen 300 Millionen aus Berlin und eine
halbe Milliarde 500 Millionen alleine
aus dem hessischen Haushalt selbst bei
den Grünen droht grundsätzlicher Streit
darüber wer wie was schaffen soll es
wird zu viel wir können das nicht mehr
leisten ganz sachlich differenziert
bräuchten wir eigentlich jetzt in
Anführungszeichen
eine Verschnaufpause bei der weiteren
Zuwanderung lange hat sich der Kanzler
taub gestellt jetzt will Scholz es zur
Chefsache machen
Parlaments Redaktion hat die Politik
einfach die schlichte Zahl der Menschen
unterschätzt die da kommt oder gehofft
dass die alle privat unterkommen oder
was ist das Problem
das ist nicht und das ist unterschätzt
hat glaube ich jetzt nicht das war ja
absehbar bei Kriegsbeginn die ersten
Tage schon waren ja in der der Berliner
Hauptbahnhof und sozusagen ganz
Deutschland überfüllt mit den ausreisen
wir erinnern uns an die vollen
Autobahnen von Menschen die die Ukraine
fluchtartig verlassen hatten das Problem
ist halt dass sie auf ein Land trafen in
dem einerseits schon relativ viele
Flüchtlinge aus den vergangenen Jahren
sind und in den ähm ansonsten natürlich
irgendwie die Kapazitäten begrenzt waren
und sie kam halt alle auf einen Schlag
also alle innerhalb von Wochen und
vielleicht Monaten das hat natürlich zu
einer Situation des ja der anfänglichen
Überforderung geführt und jetzt
verlagert sich das Problem natürlich in
gewisser Weise das zunächst waren ja
viele auch privat untergebracht und so
weiter manche wollen jetzt aus der
privaten Unterbringung raussuchen eigene
Wohnung und so weiter dazu kommt jetzt
eine steigende Anzahl von Asylbewerbern
also Menschen die nicht aus der Ukraine
kommen sondern aus anderen Länder die
hier Asylanträge stellen
und die Leute sind eben nicht mehr in
der Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung sondern
jetzt werden jetzt auf die Kommunen
verteilt und das führt natürlich zu
einer Situation die jedenfalls
deutschlandweit in vielen Kommunen
also hören wir es und so haben wir jetzt
gerade im Film gehört an der
Belastungsgrenze sind oder schon darüber
hinaus wir werden gleich die Politik
dazu hören noch mal zurück zu diesen
Ukrainern und bleiben wir doch zunächst
mal bei denen die im Land sind 1,1
Millionen das ist eine unglaubliche Zahl
hat man gehofft dass die früher wieder
gehen dass sie früher wieder weg sind
ich glaube so eine echte Hoffnung konnte
man jedenfalls nicht haben weil niemand
ja wusste wie das in der Ukraine
weitergeht es war ja diese erste
Eindruck dass die Ukraine bin weniger
Tage besiegt wird hat sich ja dann als
falsch herausgestellt zu Glück würde ich
sagen
nach wie vor haben wir ja furchtbare ein
furchtbaren Krieg der da tobt und
deswegen sind ja einige für mich
eigentlich erstaunlich zurückgegangen
die so mutig sind zu sagen ich gehe
trotzdem zurück entweder verteidige ich
mein Land oder ich gehe an die Orte wo
es vielleicht etwas sicherer ist aber
dass die Menschen in dieser Lage jetzt
alle wieder in ihre Heimat zurückgehen
ist glaube ich eine naive Vorstellung
gewesen und ich habe aus der Politik
auch nicht vernommen dass viele damit
wirklich gerechnet haben das ganze war
eben also dieser Kriegsausbruch war ja
für Deutschland überraschend vielleicht
für die Welt überraschend und damit war
natürlich auch der diese große
Fluchtbewegung eine auf die Deutschland
nicht vorbereitet war dann machen wir es
doch mal konkret anders als viele
Asylbewerber dürften die Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine sofort arbeiten dass das
aber auch zu Überraschung selbst der
Flüchtlinge nicht immer so gut
funktioniert zeigen wir in unserem
Beispiel
guten Tag die Kinder die Frau Dr steuert
die kommt der ab und zu und die
begleitet uns aber Frau Dr stojak aus
der Ukraine ist nur Praktikantin über
zehn Jahre Berufserfahrung als Ärztin
sind in Deutschland erst mal nichts wert
stattdessen lebt sie von Sozialhilfe im
rheinland-pfälzischen Mülheim
ich würde mir wünschen dass die
bürokratischen Hindernisse schnell dazu
überwinden wären denn die finde ich für
uns in Deutschland eigentlich erbärmlich
erst prüft das Jobcenter dann die
Ärztekammer das dauert vielleicht Jahre
Hanna stojak flüchtete mit ihrer Tochter
Olga direkt nach Kriegsausbruch und
während Mama noch für die B2
Sprachprüfung paukt ist die elfjährige
Olga bereits versierte Übersetzerin
[Musik]
habe mit meiner Mama manchmal auch
deutsch
und natürlich darf Olga nicht mit dabei
sein aber die Mama ist hier heute bei
uns im Studio Frau Dr stojak aus
saporicia in der Ukraine sind sie
ursprünglich sie sind mit ihrer Tochter
vor 13 Monaten schon hier nach
Deutschland gekommen und haben wie
eigentlich eine Wohnung gefunden
zuerst am Anfang
haben wir bei einer deutschen Familie
gewohnt in Bogen neben wirklich
und dann ich habe für meine Freundinnen
eine Wohnung gesucht und gefragt andere
Leute und ja ganze Sache ich habe nur
gute Leute kennengelernt und sie haben
mich geholfen ich habe Wohnung und nicht
nur bei meiner für meine Freundinnen
gesucht haben für mich auch in München
ja und dann sind Sie im pfälzischen
Müllheim sie sind Kinderärztin mit 10
Jahren Berufserfahrung und haben jetzt
sozialhälfte wie fühlt sich das an
ja das ist etwas Neues für mich weil im
Ukraine ich habe ganze Zeit gearbeitet
und war selbstständig und das ist nicht
so einfach für mich jetzt verstehen dass
ich muss soziale Geld bekommen und ich
möchte arbeiten gehen wie schnell wie
möglich sie arbeiten als Praktikantin in
dieser Praxis mit einem sehr guten
deutschen Arzt zusammen und machen
parallel dazu noch einen Sprachkurs wie
lange haben Sie auf den gewartet Frau
Doktor von meiner B2 durch Kurs ich habe
fünf Monate gewartet auf den Kurs 5
Monate gewartet ja und was glauben Sie
wie lange das jetzt dauern wird hier in
Deutschland bis man ihre Approbation
anerkennt und sie als Ärztin arbeiten
dürfen bis Produktion ich denke es kann
ein Jahr und oder zwei Jahre dauert das
kann verschiedene Zeit sein weil das
Verbinden mit dem
Anerkennung
all ihre Ausbildungen natürlich und auch
der Sprachprüfung machen müssen
dann ähm zwei Jahre arbeiten
wir rechnen mit allem und vor allen
Dingen noch mit viel Zeit und jetzt ist
natürlich die Stimme der Politik gefragt
ähm Marlo 3er Ministerpräsidentin von
Rheinland-Pfalz Frau Dreier ist das das
Problem von Frau Dr steuert was wir
gerade erzählt bekommen haben oder ist
es ein deutsches Problem
zunächst will ich mal sagen und das hat
Frau Dr steuerk eben auch betont wir
haben sehr viele Vertriebene aus der
Ukraine wir haben viele Flüchtlinge aber
was bewundert wir haben Krieg mitten in
Europa und die Menschen Rheinland-Pfalz
haben wirklich nicht nur Türen sondern
auch Herzen geöffnet und die
Vertriebenen wirklich auch sehr
großartig aufgenommen und deshalb finde
ich ist es mal wichtig erst zu sagen
Danke an alle die das machen viele im
Ehrenamt viele aus großer Überzeugung
aber auch die Kommunen die
landesaufnahmestellen allen die
beteiligt sind die Jobcenter das läuft
wirklich auch private Initiative auch
private Initiative oder die wären wir
glaube ich aufgeschmissen aber ich sag's
auch noch mal auch viele Mitarbeiter
Mitarbeiterin in den Jobcentern dort wo
die Flüchtlinge versorgt werden in den
Kommunen auch viele hauptamtlicher
es hat mich sehr bedrückt als ich die
Geschichte von Frau Dr Steuer gesehen
habe schon vor ein paar Tagen also nicht
vor dieser Sendung und bin sofort auf
Recherche gegangen was ist los los und
ich habe eben auch mit ihr gesprochen
natürlich brauchen wir einen Antrag und
wir möchten auch wir haben noch keinen
Antrag aber wir möchten gerne ich habe
meinem Gesundheitsminister gesagt wie
ich die von dieser Situation gehört habe
dass wir zu dem Bundesländern gehören
müssen in absehbarer Zeit die zu den
schnellsten Anerkennungen kommen wir
brauchen Ärzte und Ärztinnen wir
wünschen uns dass die Vertriebenen die
bei uns sind berufstätig sein können sie
haben die Qualifikation und es geht
eigentlich gar nicht dass wir diese
Qualifikation nicht anerkennen können
klar Sprachkurs muss sein der ist ja
auch schon abgesenkt worden auf B2 durch
das Bundesgesundheitsministerium aber
natürlich müssen wir auch mit den
entsprechenden Stellen sprechen wie
können die Verfahren beschleunigen und
das finde ich sehr sehr wichtig da ist
eine erste Aussage wir sind mit Hendrik
wüst verbunden in Düsseldorf der
Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen ist uns zugeschaltet
er wüsst warum hat Deutschland so ein
Problem Ukraine zu beschäftigen 20%
sind es nach jetzigen Stand nach 13
Monaten andere Länder Niederlande z.B
die Polen haben 65% der Ukraine schon in
Beschäftigung was machen diese Länder
besser als wir
ich glaube man muss sehr genau
hinschauen wer dazu uns gekommen ist
viele junge Mütter mit kleinen Kindern
wir haben ein hohes Anforderungsniveau
was unseren Arbeitsmarkt angeht und wir
haben eben auch da sieht man hier an dem
Beispiel eben leider auch Beispiel auf
ganz gut
kapazitätsthemen überall wenn frau dr
stojak fünf Monate auf Sprachkurs warten
muss das ist nicht nur in
Rheinland-Pfalz das bei uns in
Nordrhein-Westfalen auch nicht besser
dann sieht man eben daran dass wir
natürlich nicht in jeder einzelnen
Facette so gut aufgestellt waren so gut
zu kurzer Zeit so viele Menschen
aufzunehmen sofort die Sprachkurse
Integrationskurse und alles was man
braucht parat zu haben was gehört zur
Wahrheit mit dazu und trotzdem war es
natürlich richtig im letzten Jahr die
die die Türen zu öffnen wer vor
putinskrieg fliegt war bei uns herzlich
willkommen und ist es auch heute was
muss Boris Palma ist bei uns der ja
nicht ganz unbekannte Oberbürgermeister
von Tübingen die sind gerade
wiedergewählt worden für acht Jahre was
muss ich sofort ändern damit eine Ärztin
nicht weiter Sozialhilfe bekommt dieser
13 Monaten hier in Deutschland arbeitet
wir müssen von den deutschen
bürokratischen Standards runter nämlich
ziemlich einfach die Antwort ich würde
sie morgen arbeiten lassen weil sie es
kann und den Papierkram einfach mal zur
Seite legen schnell nur Zeit und da muss
man anders vorgehen als wenn man sich
beliebig lange Zeit lassen kann und das
hat ja noch eine andere Seite nicht nur
für sie ist es ja
fast schon den würdigend nicht von ihrer
Arbeit leben zu können sondern es gibt
ja auch noch das Problem dass in vielen
Kommunen Ärzte sowieso schon fehlen und
das auch in den Städten die Hausärzte
sein wir können eigentlich keine
Patienten mehr aufnehmen aber 1,1
Millionen Menschen die jetzt neu dazu
gekommen sind brauchen ärztliche
Versorgung als ich das mit meinem grünen
Kollegen Jens marco scherfdiskutiert
hatte er vorgeschlagen dann sollten wir
halt da wo es keine ärztliche Versorgung
gibt die Zuweisung von Flüchtlingen
nicht mehr vornehmen das wird nicht
gehen weil es gibt fast nirgends diese
Reserven aber man könnte doch und das
ist unser gemeinsamer Vorschlag in den
Brief an den Bundeskanzler könnte doch
sagen es gibt es Instituts des Arzt im
Praktikum der darf bereits untersuchen
der verdient dann noch nicht nicht voll
der darf noch nicht verschreiben aber es
gibt ja viele ukrainische Patienten
warum kann sie nicht morgen als Arzt im
Praktikum einfach anfangen und für die
Patienten für die wir keine Hausärzte
haben die Versorgung sicherstellen dass
sowas in Deutschland nicht möglich ist
zeigt unser Problem wir haben das
gleiche in den anderen knappen Bereichen
genauso im Ausländeramt macht uns die
Bürokratie des Lebens schwer kriegt sie
keine Aufenthaltserlaubnis wenn sie
nicht gerade aus der Ukraine ist in den
Kitas müssen die höchsten Standards
gelten können man keine Kitaplätze zur
Verfügung stellen wir müssen in die
Diskussion über Bürokratie und Standards
einsteigen anders ist dieser große
Zustrom nicht mehr zu bewältigen der DR
Bauer hätte das gerne auch angeregt für
sie dass sie schon arbeiten dürfen und
das tun sie ja und natürlich auch erst
recht die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge
betreuen könnten Frau Dreier weil du
unbedingt sagen wenn ich die Verfahren
richtig im Kopf habe gibt es auch eine
Berufsbefugnis für Ärztinnen und Ärzte
bevor die komplette Anerkennung
ausgesprochen ist das wäre ein
schnellerer Zwischenschritt und den
müssen wir jetzt auch nachgehen mit
Antrag geht nicht anders aber das ist
schon auch eine Erleichterung dass man
nicht abwarten muss bis die komplette
abrupation anerkannt wird sondern dass
man vorher eben auch als Arzt oder
Ärztin tätig sein kann also ich glaube
es ist einerseits richtig und
andererseits sind wir alle gefordert
Ukraine und Ukraine auch andere Menschen
die zu uns kommen die möchten gerne
arbeiten und gleichzeitig kämpfen wir
mit einem Fachkräftemangel und wir wären
wirklich verrückt wenn wir es nicht
schaffen würden diese Verfahren auch
zunehmend wirklich zu erleichtern und
ich kann nur anbieten es sollte kein
Problem werden vielleicht ist es nicht
ganz einfach aber wir haben uns
vorgenommen dass wir gerade was die
Anerkennung der Ärztinnen betrifft
wirklich auch schneller werden es sind
insgesamt sieben Prozent medizinisches
Personal das aus der Ukraine kam sagt
man ungefähr also ärztepfleger und
Krankenschwestern
wie noch mal was könnten Sie sagen Frau
Dr Steuer war das absurdeste Beispiel
auch an Bürokratie dass sie erlebt haben
in Bezug auf Ämter in Bezug auf
Öffnungszeiten in Bezug auf Dinge die
Sie tun sollten zum Beispiel offen
öffnungszeiten
ja zum Beispiel und ich verstehe das ist
viele viele Fragen und wie sie haben
viele Arbeit und nicht so viel
Mitarbeiterin und das geht nicht so
schnell
zu ändern
zum Beispiel jetzt warte ich auf Antwort
von meiner
Vertrag mit übersetzen und meine
Dokumenten ist damit Sie all diese
Dokumente haben und sie tippen das haben
sie vorhin gesagt das braucht noch zwei
Jahre wir hoffen dass es vielleicht
nicht zwei Jahre braucht und dann denken
sehr dass sie heute bei uns in der
Sendung sind und wünschen natürlich
alles Gute ich marschiere zurück in die
Runde Frau Bobrowski wir haben parallel
dazu ja auch ein
unterbringungsproblem in Deutschland und
zwar ein massives weil die Menschen eben
in private Wohnungen und Aufnahme
Situationen kamen aber die natürlich aus
allen Nähten platzen
wonach entscheidet sich eigentlich und
zwar unabhängig ob Ukrainer oder andere
Flüchtling ob eine Kommune eine Stadt
überfordert ist also Lörrach ist ja auch
so ein Beispiel gewesen wir waren ins
ukrainische Flüchtlinge oder ob das gut
funktioniert was sagt die schlaue
faktionalistin ich kann ja nur von
Berlin aus drauf schauen und da sieht
man auch vieles nicht muss ich sagen das
aber was ich höre und das sind eine
Frage die ich versucht habe nachzugehen
und was man was eine Frage ist die für
mich noch unbeantwortet ist ist nach
welchen Kriterien eigentlich die
Bundesländer auf welche Kommunen
zuweisen das kann auch das
Bundesinnenministerium nicht richtig
beantworten da scheint auch der
informationsausdruck nicht immer sehr
gut zu funktionieren es gibt ja Kommunen
das habe ich mir kürzlich angeschaut in
Bayern wo sehr viel Leerstand ist denn
auch da gibt es das Phänomen der
Landflucht und wo überhaupt kein
einziger ukrainischer Flüchtling
untergebracht ist in einer wirklich
größeren Region und dann gibt es andere
Kommunen würde sagen bei uns sind viel
zu viele und das hängt dann teilweise
glaube ich an auch an Zufälligkeiten und
das sind Fragen auch der der Verteilung
innerhalb der Bundesländer die sich
jedenfalls mir und und anderen
sind noch mal die die man zuweisen kann
das stimmt und trotzdem ist es ja so
dass man vielleicht irgendwelche Anreize
setzen könnte
woanders hinzugehen um eine bessere
Verteilung hinzubekommen oder also wir
kommen zu der Verteilung der
Asylbewerber noch bleiben wir noch mal
bei den Ukrainern Frau Dreier um das
Problem zu verstehen also ähm sie haben
eine freie Wohnort Wahl die ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge auch daran wird jetzt so ein
bisschen genagt glauben Sie dass man das
verändern müsste um Menschen eben aus
der Ukraine gezielter in bestimmten
Städten unterzubringen also was war die
Idee dahinter die Menschen erleben einen
furchtbaren Krieg mitten in Europa und
es leid ist gigantisch und es ist
einfach total nachvollziehbar dass
Menschen Anlaufstellen suchen wo sie
andere Menschen kennen oder
Andockstellen haben oder Vereine oder
Organisationen haben und so haben sich
die ukrainischen Vertriebenen auch
verteilt und natürlich gibt es
Unterstützung vor Ort wo Menschen dann
auch sagen kommt doch in unser Dorf wir
nehmen Euch gerne auf wir haben Wohnraum
wir haben das ein ganz vielen Stellen in
Rheinland-Pfalz erlebt und Dörfer gesagt
haben bei uns steht ein Haus leer wir
nehmen Euch gerne ein paar ab und wir
wir kümmern uns und das hat eigentlich
auch ganz gut funktioniert also ich
würde sagen den Anspruch den Deutschland
daran hatte die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge
menschengerecht aufzunehmen hat
Deutschland auch erfüllt nämlich dass
wir nicht gesagt haben wir bauen ein
Popanz auf die Leute müssen sich
irgendwo melden sie werden verteilt sie
laufen durch den Asylsystem was auch
immer sondern das wollten wir alles
nicht und ich glaube dass wir da auch
sehr vorausschauen gehandelt haben klar
die Herausforderungen sind riesig das
will ich auch gar nicht verleugnen aber
man muss das immer auch noch mal so ein
Relation setzen es sind von Mainz der
Landeshauptstadt 15 Autostunden entfernt
dann sind wir mitten im kriegsgebet und
es ist einfach schlimm was da passiert
insofern glaube ich hat sich das bei uns
im Land mit den ukrainischen
Flüchtlingen eigentlich ganz gut
geregelt noch mal die Frage nach
Düsseldorf Herr wüst 20 Prozent der
Ukraine wie gesagt diese 1,1 Millionen
Menschen sind in Deutschland in Arbeit
haben es also automatisch auch leichter
Wohnraum zu finden und ihnen sogar zu
bezahlen wo würden sie das größte
Problem ausmachen warum gelingt es uns
ich frage es noch mal so schlecht die
Ukraine auch in entsprechende Arbeit zu
bringen
ich will noch mal sagen was ich gerade
schon gesagt habe wir müssen schauen wer
da kommt wir müssen schauen wer da kommt
viele Mütter mit kleinen Kindern
lese ich in den verschiedensten Studien
es sind junge Frauen mit Kindern gut
dann reden wir über Kindergartenplätze
oder reden wir nämlich über die
Standards der Palma hat den Punkt gerade
schon gemacht und er hat vollkommen
recht wir können jeden Tag als Politiker
nur dankbar sein dass die Erzieherinnen
und Erzieher das Mitmachen dass die
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer in den
Grundschulen das Mitmachen die machen
das weil sie ein großes Herz haben wenn
die uns das vor die Füße schmeißen dann
gucken wir alle ganz schön dumm aus der
Wäsche also da ist eine riesen Belastung
und man muss auch sehen da kommen
Menschen aus dem schlimmen Kriegsgebiet
mit einer mit einer Traumatisierung ich
glaube nicht dass das erste Thema ist
Kinder in die Kita und Mutter sucht ihn
Arbeitsplatz das muss man muss glaube
ich das wirklich immer mal mit dem
Praktikern mal besprechen dann lernt man
eine Menge warum da was geht und was da
nicht geht ich kenne tolle Beispiele die
20% jedes davon ist ein einzeln ganz
tolles Beispiel aber ich kenne auch
viele wo die Kinder wirklich auch die
Mama noch brauchen oft weil sie schlimme
Dinge gesehen haben insofern wir haben
es hier ja nicht wir haben es hier nicht
mit Arbeitsmigration zu tun sondern mit
Kriegsflüchtlingen sondern das müssen
wir über Kitas reden und über die
Standards das war auch in den Brief von
Herrn Palma und seinem Kollegen richtig
beschrieben wenn wir die jetzt alle in
die regelkitas packen da ist jetzt viel
gelaufen man kann nur dankbar dafür sein
aber wir haben hier Brücken Projekte
gemacht niedrigere Standard also bei uns
heißt das Brückenprojekt was ist das was
Herr Palma anregt das ist das gleiche
wie mit den Sprachkursen auch wir müssen
uns jetzt mal mit niedrigeren Standards
am Einstieg äh zufrieden gehen wenn
jemand Monate lang auf den parkkurs
wartet ist es besser er hat vielleicht
jemand von jemand der das einfach mit
dem großen Herzen und mit dieser
Erfahrung macht und noch nicht das
Zertifikat nachher erteilen kann das
kommt dann vielleicht später und bei den
Kitas ist es das gleiche ich glaube da
müssen wir jetzt wirklich pragmatisch
sein
an Herrn Palma weiter weil wir genau
heute pragmatisch sein wollen und uns
mit den Menschen befassen wollen die
hier im Lande sind ihr Argument war dass
das viele Mütter mit Kindern sind warum
sind die Mütter mit Kindern in den
Niederlanden und in Polen und in
Tschechien zu 65% beschäftigt ich möchte
nur verstehen diese eine Nachfrage als
nächstes ist der Palma dran
kann Ihnen das im Einzelnen Teil auch
gar nicht sagen warum der die eine die
eine bessere Arbeit findet als die
andere wenn ich diese Menschen treffe
und ich habe sie oft getroffen dann sehe
ich eben auch Menschen die sich sehr um
ihre Kinder noch kümmern müssen weil sie
die nicht einfach in die Kita bringen
können wenn andere Länder das besser
hinkriegen müssen was das anschauen
vielleicht haben die Länder auch weil
sie viel viel weniger Menschen
aufgenommen haben unsere Freundinnen
Niederlanden sind ziemlich genauso groß
wie Nordrhein-Westfalen was die
Bevölkerung angeht haben ein Drittel
genommen vielleicht klappt das dann mit
Anerkennung mit Anerkennung schneller
vielleicht klappt das dann mit
Sprachkursen schneller wenn sie auf
Polen und Tschechien gehen dann ist die
Versorgung da eine völlig andere der
arbeitsanreiz ein viel größerer das sind
völlig andere Arbeitsmärkte es kann also
in den Niederlanden ein anderer Grund
sein die die geringere kopfzahlen die
bessere Möglichkeit Sprachkurse zu
machen und ähnliches und in Polen und
Tschechien ist es halt völlig andere
Arbeitsmarkt und eine nicht so gute
Versorgung materiell und dadurch ein
höherer Druck auch arbeiten zu gehen
wir sind bei Herrn Palmer und sagen Herr
Palma ihr Befund ist es ist jetzt von
allem zu wenig und eigentlich ist unser
nächster Schritt als Kommune Leistungen
zu kürzen weil es sind so viele Menschen
dass ich nicht mehr anbieten kann was
jemandem der als Kriegsflüchtling nach
Tübingen kommt braucht Wohnung aber am
allerliebsten auch Arbeit Kitaplatz
Unterricht und so oder eben dann auch
das Bürgergeld heißt dass sie schlagen
vor als nächstes bei allen zu kürzen
heißt dass sie schlagen vor bei den
Neuankömmlingen zu kürzen was denken sie
müssen Sie als nächstes tun
erstmal möchte ich auch unterstreichen
das überhaupt nicht in Frage steht dass
die Menschen aus der Ukraine bei uns
aufgenommen werden darum geht's nicht
unterstellt auch niemand aber ab zur
Klarstellung auch da bin ich ganz klar
dieser Meinung jetzt geht es um die
Frage wie wir knappe Güter verteilen da
wäre auch mal wichtig einzuerkennen dass
die knapp sind weil oft würde man
entgegen gehalten wer sagt das ist knapp
der will in Wahrheit nicht helfen nicht
der Fall knapp sind Kita-Plätze nehmen
wir dieses Beispiel wenn Herr wüst Recht
hat das in Deutschland die Versorgung
mit Kitaplätzen Hindernis ist eine
Arbeit aufzunehmen dann stelle ich
erstmal fest das ist schon so knapp dass
auch ohne den Strom aus der Ukraine
wegen der fehlenden man
absolut Menschen nicht arbeiten können
oder ihre Arbeit zurückfahren müssen
weil sie keine Betreuung finden wenn ich
jetzt noch weitere Menschen die nie
irgendwo in der Bedarfsplanung drin
waren die zu mir wird es noch
problematische dann habe ich zwei
Möglichkeiten die eine ich nehme denen
die schon da waren weitere
Betreuungszeiten weg
oder die andere ich finde Möglichkeit
die neu angekommenen in den eigenen
System zu bringen ich würde das machen
wenn ich dürfte darf ich aber nicht denn
sobald eine Spielgruppe mehr als zehn
Stunden Betreuungszeit hat gelten die
vollen Kitas dann dazu Baden-Württemberg
das heißt da müssen Fachkräfte
angestellt werden und Fachkräfte sind
natürlich die Menschen aus der Ukraine
nicht haben wir gerade gehört bis die
anerkannt sind vergehen viele Jahre und
die einfachen sich aufdrängende
Möglichkeit so würde ich machen wenn ich
durfte zu sagen freie Kindergarten
Häuser haben wir sowieso sind neu gebaut
sind noch nicht bezogen weil wir die
Leute nicht finden Spielsachen sind auch
kein Problem bei ihnen Baggern auch noch
nicht Bagger an diesem 400.000 Wohnungen
die der Bund versprochen hat leider auch
nicht aber das könnten wir alles
bereitstellen wenn es jetzt erlaubt wäre
dass die ukrainischen geflüchteten
selber Spielgruppen aufbauen wollte halt
die Kinder auf Ukrainisch betreut werden
ohne diese ganzen bürokratischen
Standards könnten die Mütter arbeiten
und die Kinder werden betreut weil sie
nicht während ich sofort in der im
sprachbad und im Integrationsweg das
gebe ich zu aber
wir wissen ja noch gar nicht ob die hier
bleiben wollen die Ukraine hat Interesse
dass die Menschen zurückkommen das wäre
ein guter Zwischenschritt und den darf
ich aber nicht und darauf will ich
fragen darf
pragmatische Lösungen realisieren und
verhindert nicht alles mit Vorschriften
so sind die Regeln das Problem vor drei
oder sind die Menschen das Problem die
so eine Regel nicht einfach mal
überspringen
ich kann nicht mitreden in
Baden-Württemberg was dafür Regeln
herrschen ich weiß auch nicht warum in
Tübingen nicht ausreichend Kitaplätze
geschaffen werden Herr Palmers hat kein
Problem damit es gibt auch bei uns
Kommunen die Probleme haben aber ich
glaube wir haben kein Problem bei dem
Thema Spielgruppen Tagesgruppen also ich
weiß dass viele viele ukrainische Mütter
auch weil sie im Moment noch gar nicht
bereit waren die Kinder direkt eine Kita
zu geben sich wirklich selbst
organisiert haben ihnen davon in den
Gemeinden und ja kleine Gruppen hatten
gestaltet haben und da bin ich auch
absolut dafür ich bin auch besser davon
überzeugt dass er wüst sagt es gibt
einfach viele Mütter diesen Rückmeldung
habe ich auch meinen Ukrainerin die
sagen wir kommen aus dem Krieg wir
würden gerne einfach noch eine Zeit lang
die Kinder nicht direkt weggeben in Kita
trotzdem ich bleibe dabei wir haben die
Verpflichtung bundländer Kommunen wir
schaffen es ja auch nur gemeinsam das
ist ja die Überschrift auch gewesen wir
müssen auf allen Ebenen unsere Arbeit
machen damit die Kinder so betreut
werden dass am Ende auch Mütter arbeiten
gehen können davon wenig fest überzeugt
und es kann auch gar kein Argument sein
so haben sie es auch vielleicht nicht
gemeint hat Palma ob die ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge sich irgendwann entscheidend
zurückzugehen oder hier zu bleiben viele
möchten zurückgehen und das kann ich
total gut nachvollziehen wir wissen aber
von vielen inzwischen auch die sagen das
Land ist völlig zerstört wir können uns
sehr gut vorstellen auch ein bisschen
länger hier zu bleiben 30 Prozent sagen
dass sie gerne bleiben möchte in unserem
Interesse dass wir die besten Wege für
diese Menschen einfach Ebenen dass sie
hier gut ankommen dass sie Sprache
lernen dass sie integriert sind und dass
sie ihren Beruf üben können und daran
müssen wir gemeinsam weiterarbeiten das
ist gelingt wir sind noch mal bei dem
Herr Palma ob sie überhaupt finden dass
es richtig ist den Ukrainern diesen
Vorzug zu geben also auch sofort
Bürgergeld zu bekommen wenn man nicht
arbeitet gar kein Asylverfahren zu
stellen sagen sie aus kommunaler Sicht
das war richtig oder sagen Sie es hat
mir auch die Möglichkeit genommen als
Oberbürgermeister die Dinge eben einfach
anders zu machen wenn ich sie anders
handhaben kann nein ich glaube der Teil
war richtig aber zur Wahrheit gehört
auch dass Deutschland zehnmal mehr
ukrainische Flüchtlinge als Frankreich
aufgenommen hat liegt im Wesentlichen
daran dass man in Frankreich drastisch
weniger Geld bekommt wenn man dort
versucht wo es zu fassen das sind 500
Euro und davon soll man alles bezahlen
auch die Wohnung bei uns kriegt man eben
wesentlich mehr und diese
Ungleichverteilung an der Rheingrenze
hatten wir auch schon 2015 die Franzosen
haben sich weitgehend ausgeklinkt und es
ist schon so dass wir dann in den
Kommunen halt sagen müssen wenn wir das
alles leisten sollen werden die
Ressourcen knapp bei den Kitas in den
Schulen im Wohnungsmarkt und es 14 im
Verdrängungswettbewerb gegenüber denen
die schon da waren und es wird finde ich
nicht ehrlich diskutiert weil man sich
dem nicht stellen möchte ich nämlich
wirklich nicht schön die Diskussion sie
haben Entschuldigung fragen wir gleich
nach sie sagen im Grunde genommen sind
unsere Sozialstandards in Deutschland so
hoch im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern in
der anderen Europa in Westeuropa dass
die Ukraine am allerliebsten nach
Deutschland kommen sie würden es nicht
wie Friedrich Merz sozialtourismus
nennen aber ich würde sagen es ist ein
Fakt dass unsere Sozialstandards ich
gehe sogar noch weiter vor den 500 Euro
kann man fast nicht leben in Frankreich
doch völlig logisch dass ich dann in
Deutschland bleibe nicht über den Rhein
weitergeht ist doch klar wie sind ihre
positive Position dazu Herr wüst würden
Sie Friedrich Merz hat das Wort vom
sozialtourismus natürlich zurückgenommen
aber sagen Sie auch unsere
Sozialstandards in Deutschland sind auch
ein zusätzlicher Anreiz für ukrainische
Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland zu kommen
ich glaube das zu bestreiten wäre falsch
wir sind da jetzt an einem ganz
entscheidenden Punkt der Diskussion wir
haben das ja auch damals gemacht die
Bundesregierung hat vorgeschlagen die
Länder haben das auch dann mitgemacht
weil wir auch die Chance gesehen haben
dadurch eine schnellere Vermittlung in
Arbeit zu gewährleisten jetzt haben wir
darüber ja gerade schon diskutiert 20
Prozent sind jetzt nicht toll nicht so
toll wie andere aber da werden wir noch
lange nicht wenn wir normal Asylsystem
wären das ist auch die Wahrheit deswegen
haben wir das gemacht und es beschreibt
eben auch eins die Menschen werden
länger bleiben am Anfang ist darüber
diskutiert worden welche Prognosen wir
gemacht haben haben alle überhaupt gar
keine Prognosen gemacht sondern haben
erstmal geholfen jetzt sehen wir aber
die Menschen werden bleiben viele von
ihnen sehr lange manche sicherlich auch
für immer wenn man sich den Zustand der
Städte dort anschaut und deswegen glaube
ich müssen wir uns hier ein Stück
ehrlich machen was das ganze Thema
Standards auch Dauerhaftigkeit von
Finanzierung angeht wir müssen auch
darüber Geld reden ist nicht der
entscheidende Punkt bisher gewesen in
unserer Debatte das gehört auch dazu wir
brauchen verlässliche Strukturen und die
können wir nur aufbauen die können die
Kommunen nur aufbauen wenn Sie auch
wissen dass sie dafür einen fairen
Anteil von Bund und Ländern bekommen wir
reden heute Abend möchte ich immer
wieder betonen über die Menschen die
schon im Land sind und weniger darüber
was der Bund natürlich auch noch mit den
anderen Ländern Europas versucht an
Fairness innerhalb Europas und
verteilungszahlen zu verändern vor
Bobrowski aber ist es denn vermittelbar
dass wir sagen unsere Sozialstandards
dürfen eben nicht erhöht werden damit
die geflüchteten und oder Asylbewerber
nicht weiter in erster Linie nach
Deutschland kommen also zum einen muss
man ja sagen bei diesen Fragen gibt es
ja in Deutschland relativ strenge
rechtliche Vorgaben auch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat gerade im
letzten November noch mal entschieden
dass eine bestimmte
Absenkung unter ein Niveau für
Asylbewerber verfassungswidrig ist also
da sind da sind die Standards in
Deutschland eben auch abgesichert über
das Grundgesetz sehr sehr hoch trotzdem
gibt es auch Wissenschaftler die sagen
man könnte in einem europäischen Verbund
sozusagen als binnenmarktidee eine
Angleichung der Sozialstandards finden
wobei auch das natürlich schwierig ist
weil auch die Lebenshaltungskosten
natürlich völlig unterschiedlich sind in
den unterschiedlichen Ländern
ich weiß nicht wir reden ja hier über
Pragmatismus und schnelle Lösungen und
so weiter ich weiß nicht ob das also der
Versuch unter 27 Mitgliedstaaten sich
auf da auf einen einen Standard zu
einigen ob das was ist was sozusagen
unter in die Kategorie schnell und
pragmatisch fällt also sind ja nicht ich
wollte nicht über Europa reden sondern
ich wollte sagen muss und kann
Deutschland etwas ändern kann können wir
etwas an unseren Sozialstaat also Regeln
ich habe ja gesagt also für manche
Fragen ist das ist das ähm ist das
verfassungsrechtlich geregelt in anderen
Dingen ist es ähm
gut wir haben uns entschieden oder
Deutschland hat sich entschieden im Juni
war das glaube ich diesen
rechtskreiswechsel zu machen in
sogenannten also da war ja die Frage war
ja offen und zunächst also ob die
Ukraine unter das
Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz fallen oder
ob sie direkt Zugang zu Hartz IV also
jetzt Bürgergeld bekommen und da hat man
sich aus Gründen glaube ich das
Pragmatismus der Einfachheit den Leuten
dieses bürokratische Verfahren zu
ersparen ehrlich gesagt auch um die um
das Bundesamt für Migration und
Flüchtlinge und die Verwaltung
das ganze pragmatisch zu lösen und ich
würde sagen es gibt in so einer
Situation
keine perfekte Lösung und deshalb war
damals die Entscheidung und da kann man
jetzt im Nachhinein sagen das bringt
auch Probleme mit sich aber trotzdem war
sie wahrscheinlich zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt richtig weil sie pragmatisch
war und das ist glaube ich absolutes
Gebot der Stunde die Entscheidung für
das SBB 2 der wüst wird sich sehr gut
daran erinnern ich erinnere mich sehr
gut daran ich war eine absolute
befürworterung warum es hat gar nichts
mit dem BAMF zu tun wir haben erlebt so
15 16
so viele Kriegsflüchtlinge durch als
süßsystem zu schleusen war einfach
falsch und zwar Grotten falsch wir
wollten den Ukrainer innen und kokaina
eine gute Möglichkeit finden einfach
irgendwo Schutz und Sicherheit zu
erhalten und deshalb haben sie auch
keinen Bürgergeld sondern sie haben
Grundsicherung und sie haben die Chance
sofort in den Arbeitsmarkt integriert zu
werden ich will auch noch mal ein
bisschen relativieren kann sein dass
Niederlande und andere viel besser sind
wenn wir aber mal darauf schauen nicht
alle Ukrainer sind in der ersten Woche
gekommen wir haben in Rheinland-Pfalz
knapp 45.000 Ukrainerin 6600 davon sind
in Arbeit andere sind Integrationskosten
andere wiederum in
Ausbildungsverhältnissen wir sind nicht
so schlecht gemessen daran was in der
Vergangenheit im Zusammenhang mit
Integrationen Arbeitsmarkt betrifft und
ich kann nur sagen wir haben damals die
richtige Entscheidung getroffen auch im
übrigen der Bund zahlt das ganze ich
will es einmal gesagt haben der Bund
zahlt die Integrationsleistungen die
Lebenshaltungskosten natürlich müssen
keine Sorgen das ist vollkommen klar es
ist eine völlig anderes Systematik als
das asylbewerberleistungssitz und das
entlastet die Kommunen und die Länder
sehr stark und deshalb auch noch mal
zurückblickend auf das was am Anfang
gezeigt worden ist wer heute behauptet
Olaf Scholz und der Bundeskanzler den
Bundesregierung machen jetzt auf den
möchte ich einfach sagen es ist einfach
völlig falsch mir saßen damals zusammen
in Hamm die grundsätzliche Entscheidung
getroffen dass der Bund sehr viel
Verantwortung übernimmt und wenn ich nie
Jobcenter schaue was die dafür einen Job
machen von heute auf morgen kann ich nur
sagen gut ab und ich glaube dass wir in
der nächsten Monaten erleben werden das
zunehmend mehr Ukraine und Ukraine in
den Arbeit münden werden sie möchten
gerne arbeiten und ich glaube es ist der
richtige Weg den wir gewählt da muss
jetzt Herr wüst aber auch noch die
Gelegenheit zurückblick haben weil wenn
ich sie heute richtig verstanden habe
haben sie aus allen Rohren das Gegenteil
gesagt und gesagt der Bund muss endlich
mehr Geld geben es wird viel mehr kosten
wir marschieren jetzt gedanklich langsam
zu den Asylbewerbern auch da brauchen
sie Unterstützung und wenigstens 16
Milliarden war das so heute
16 Milliarden ist die Zahl die die
Länder im in ihren Haushalten haben und
vorgesehen haben in diesem Jahr für
Flüchtlinge auszugeben in
Nordrhein-Westfalen sind das 3,7
Milliarden dann schalten wir die Zahl
von 16 Milliarden plausibel zu sein der
Bund gibt uns nach dem bisherigen
Verabredungen hier 600 Millionen das
sind knapp 17 Prozent insofern haben wir
schon ein Thema zu besprechen vor drei
hat gerade das Thema Ukraine und die
gewählte Systematik ja richtig
beschrieben seitdem ist aber was
passiert und das darf man wenn sie jetzt
zum Thema Asyl kommen wollen auch mal in
Zahlen Ansprechen im letzten Frühjahr
als die Menschen aus der Ukraine kam
hatten wir relativ wenig Menschen die
aus Syrien Afghanistan gekommen sind das
war im Herbst aber wieder andersrum seit
November sind die Zahlen signifikant
andersrum ich will mal die Januar Zahlen
für Nordrhein-Westfalen beschreiben über
6000 Menschen aus Afghanistan Syrien
Türkei Irak Iran und anderen Ländern
6000 aus der Ukraine nur noch anderthalb
Tausend und deswegen ist das was vor
drei Jahren gesagt hat richtig aber wir
haben eben heute auch in schöner
Einmütigkeit mit allen
Ministerpräsidenten Ministerpräsidenten
auf den anderen Teil der Wahrheit
geschaut und auf das was das politisch
bedeutet was wir dafür eine Entwicklung
haben denn diese Menschen die jetzt zu
uns kommen aus den anderen Ländern
treffen ja auf eine Situation wo die
Menschen aus der Ukraine schon da sind
eben der Wohnraum knapp ist Kita und
alles was wir besprochen haben eben
knapp ist das kommt jetzt sozusagen noch
dazu auch die Zahl der Asylbewerber
insgesamt sie haben das jetzt für
einzelne Länder für Nordrhein-Westfalen
und für Januar und Februar gesagt
insgesamt noch mal der Blick auf die
Jahre 2021 und 20 22
die Zahl der nicht ukraineischen
geflüchteten steigt
2021 wurden über 190.000 Erstanträge auf
Asyl gestellt
2022 beantragten mehr als
244.000 Menschen Asyl in Deutschland das
ist ein Anstieg von
27,9% im vergangenen Jahr
und den Anstieg den sie für Januar und
Februar ausmachen der liegt dann schon
über 70 der Innenexperte der CDU im
Deutschen Bundestag Herr wüst spricht
von einer neuen
migrationskrise ist es die nicht oder
darf man das nur nicht so nennen
naja wenn Sie die Dynamik sehen die ich
gerade beschrieben habe im vergangenen
Jahr im Januar sind nicht 6.000 nach
Nordrhein-Westfalen gekommen sondern
nicht einmal 3000 also eine signifikante
Anstieg mehr als Verdoppelung sie sind
jetzt beim Jahr 2021 eingestiegen da
waren ja auch vorher schon welche da das
ist ja nur noch on top gekommen deswegen
haben wir auch heute noch mal den Appell
an den Bund gerichtet sich dem Thema
noch mal deutlicher zu stellen wir haben
auch das Thema europäische Solidarität
angesprochen der Bundeskanzler hat es
selber in seiner Regierungserklärung
schon im Februar vor dem Europäischen
Rat gesagt wir brauchen eine gemeinsame
solidarische europäische Asylpolitik ja
da geht's aber darum wer noch alles zu
uns kommt und ob wir nicht besser
verteilen können wenn wir darüber
sprechen ob wir das schaffen oder ob die
das schaffen so wie der Titel ihrer
Sendung ist müssen wir ja auch mal eine
ordentliche Prognose machen mit dem was
wir jetzt haben kommen wir einigermaßen
klar es wird knapp aber wenn jeden Monat
zigtausend Menschen nach oben drauf
kommen werden wir den Menschen nicht
gerecht wir reden über zahlen wir reden
über Geld wir reden über Recht und
Gerichtsentscheidung müssen wir aber
Menschen reden wir wollen doch diesen
Menschen gerecht werden ich habe niemand
in der Runde gehört der das nicht will
aber wir müssen es eben auch schaffen
wir müssen das eben auch können und dazu
gehört eine faire Verteilung in Europa
eine ordentliche Kontrolle und
Registrierung an den Außengrenzen
Solidarität das haben wir heute einmütig
mit allen Ministerpräsidenten
Ministerpräsidenten beschlossen auch das
Thema der finanziellen Absicherung der
Kommunen langfristige Aufwendung sollen
gemacht werden aber bisher ist die
Finanzierung geregelt bis Ostern darüber
sprechen wir dann im Mai geschenkt dass
das zu spät ist es sei darum das Thema
Rückführung ist eines es kommt viele
Menschen zu uns nur wenige auch von
denen die eigentlich ausreisen müssen
Reisen aus Rückführung sehr schwieriges
Geschäft der Bund hat sich viel
vorgenommen das muss auch passieren also
eine ganze Vielzahl an beschlossen die
wir heute gefasst haben und wo ist
dringend
daran zu gehen Latte von Aufgaben neue
migrationskrise Herr Palmer 10 Mai für
die Kommunen für die Länder und Kommunen
schon zu spät
nein das wird ja auch nicht nächstes
Jahr vorbei sein dieses Problem es ist
natürlich nicht zu spät die Geldfrage
lass ich mal außen vor das hängt auch
sehr stark davon ab wie wohl haben eine
Gegend ist das ist für mich nicht das
drückende Problem ich weiß aber anderen
Bürgermeister geht es anders da ist es
sehr wichtig dass er die Geldfrage mit
dem Bund besprochen wird mir geht es
wirklich um die Knappheit von
elementaren Gütern die auch die
kurzfristig ändern kann lassen sie mir
noch mal den Wohnungsmarkt nehmen wir
haben das gerade mal angeschaut wir
haben in Tübingen etwa 2000 Wohnungen
die nach sozialen Kriterien vergeben
werden 450 sind über die letzten sechs
sieben Jahre hinweg ein Flüchtlinge
vergeben wollen also für jede fünfte und
wenn es da immer noch mehr obendrauf
kommt heißt es neue Vergabe an Menschen
die schon da waren findet nicht mehr
statt es gibt einfach keine Wohnung die
Nacht bleiben die bleiben ja und da
kommen noch neue Flüchtlinge dazu die
haben Vorrang da bin ich
unterbringungspflichtig und werden die
obdachlos und dann gibt's einfach nichts
mehr für die die schon daran das ist
schon Verdrängungswettbewerb auf Kosten
der Menschen mit kleinen Einkommen die
kommen teilweise meine Sprechstunde und
sagen ich bin jetzt 70 habe noch länger
gearbeitet ich muss die Stadt verlassen
ich kann mir keine Wohnung mehr leisten
und der Druck wird wachsen und das
sollte man glaube ich anerkennen ich
weiß auch als will ich Ihnen gleich was
zu sagen ich weiß auch bei Ukraine gibt
es nicht zu diskutieren dann wird auch
weiterhin der private Wohnungsmarkt
Angebote schaffen aber bei denen über
die Herr wüstgrad gesprochen hat also
die klassischen
asylzuwanderungsländer der letzten Jahre
gibt es diese Bereitschaft
ehrlicherweise wenig da kommen nicht
viel Angebote muss man einfach auch zur
Kenntnis nehmen also brauchen wir
Ordnung ich bin Realist wir kriegen die
nicht in der EU Außengrenze dieses Jahr
und wir kriegen auch die Abschiebungen
nicht in Griff das wird nicht
stattfinden das heißt was wir jetzt
Markus Schärf und ich und da steht den
Tag Baden-Württemberg und der von Bayern
ich glaube immer mehr vorschlagen ist
Liebe Länder ihr müsst jetzt Ordnung
reinbringen in euren Aufnahme
Einrichtungen ihr müsst die Verfahren
dort zu Ende führen und nur die die
bleiben dürfen nur die Hälfte ist die
gesamtschutzquote ist 50% im Schnitt
über die Jahre hinweg die Hälfte der
Asylbewerber die in Deutschland einen
Antrag dürfen
bleiben die anderen müssen gehen uns
aber nicht ja und dann haben wir die
Hälfte der Leute die gar nicht bleiben
dürfen denn die Kommunen sollen sie
integrieren obwohl sie gehen müssen es
führt zu all den Konflikten die Sie
kennen und die auch viel Ärger macht
wenn Sie die dann vorher schon wüssten
die die wieder zurück müssten wäre ihnen
geholfen weil der Gedanke ich will die
gar nicht zu uns in die Kommunen kommen
die standardshöher sind da Wohnraum der
Sprachkurs der Integrationsaufwand viel
größer richtigerweise weil die wollen ja
bleiben dürfen bleiben wenn nur die
kommen dann werden wir es viel besser
schaffen und die Länder könnten die
Verfahren zu Ende führen müssten dann
aber das was sie uns im Moment immer
auferlegen mit dass wir die ganze
Versorgung schaffen sollen auf der
Kommunalwahl Ebene bedauerlicherweise
selber machen und ich finde das sind sie
eigentlich in der Pflicht da müssen sie
größer werden
Aufnahmeeinrichtungen bauen dann müssen
sie das Personal besorgen die so
knappisch müssten Sie diese Verfahren
mit dem Dampf gemeinsam zu Ende führen
wir übernehmen alle die bleiben dürfen
das wäre eine Ferien Ordnung und würde
auch den Anreiz nach Deutschland zu
kommen für die die gar kein Recht haben
deutlich reduzieren bei Sachleistungen
kursaufnahmeeinrichtung ist nicht das
wofür man dann wenn man gar keinen
Anspruch hat zu kommen sich auf den Weg
sich auf den Weg nach Deutschland macht
Frau Dreier sie haben die schöne Aufgabe
kurz zu sagen was sie davon halten also
länderaufnahmezentren Länder
ankerzentren die so lange die
Asylbewerber bewahren und betreuen bis
man weiß ob sie eigentlich ein
Bleiberecht haben also in unseren
Aufnahmeeinrichtungen gibt es keine
Sachleistungen aber wir versuchen
möchten wir nicht und wir versuchen die
Flüchtlinge so lange in unseren
Aufnahmeeinrichtungen zu halten bis klar
ist was ja Aufenthaltsstatus ist es geht
ja muss man ja auch sagen wenn man sehr
viel gelernt aus 2015/16 bei unserem
Rheinland-Pfalz dauert ein
durchschnittlich Asylverfahren drei bis
vier Monate wir haben auch die
schnellsten
verwaltungsgerichtsurteile man muss auch
sagen dass die Entscheidungen des Bands
so viel besser geworden sind das nicht
jede zweite Entscheidung aufgehoben wird
vom Gericht also da ist wirklich
Beschleunigung reingekommen und wir
bemühen uns sehr darum wir haben die
Kapazitäten im letzten Jahr verdoppelt
unserer landesaufnahmeeinrichtungen die
Kommunen wirklich drastisch zu entlasten
wir werden es nicht schaffen jeden der
geduldet wird in Deutschland in der
Aufnahmeeinrichtung zu halten weil es
einfach zu viel sind aber ich sage auch
eines der klar ich finde den Ansatz in
die Bundesregierung jetzt fährt nämlich
zu versuchen über den Sonderbeauftragten
tatsächlich Abkommen mit den
Herkunftsländern abzuschließen der ist
für mich der einzige Ansatz der am Ende
wirklich auch was bringen kann das haben
wir bei den Balkan Flüchtlingen erlebt
dort haben wir gesagt es gibt ein festes
Kondens das übernimmt Deutschland da
kann jemand legal einreisen ansonsten
verpflichten sich die Staaten
Zurücknahme das ist glaube ich ein Ziel
was wir erreichen müssen dann schaffen
wir es auch als Land die Leute sehr
schnell auch wieder zurückzubringen und
das Ziel sein ja es ist in Jahren zuvor
schon viel versprochen worden gerade in
den arabischen Raum hinein diese
Rückführungsabkommen zu schaffen und
eigentlich auch schon Jahrzehnte
sozusagen von Thomas de Maiziere reiste
durch die Länder und hat versucht diese
Abkommen abzuschließen und der Türkei
muss man sagen also wir müssen da
dranbleiben an dem Thema absolut nur ich
meine auch die Idee von Herrn Palma die
ich absolut richtig finde ist halt nicht
neu also ankerzentren wollte schon Horst
Seehofer und die diese Regierung damals
schaffen und das war dann Wort dass man
nicht mehr benutzen konnte weil es so
viel nicht nicht richtig passte das
Problem ist natürlich dass das in der in
der Theorie alles richtig ist wenn das
asyl-verfahren so funktionieren würde
wie es eigentlich vorgesehen ist jemand
kommt es wird schnell entschieden da
verbleiben oder oder muss er gehen und
dann geht er auch und solange das alles
so läuft bleibt dann eine Einrichtung
und da so war ja auch die Idee schon
damals werden alle alle Behörden
vertreten sein und sogar einen Vertreter
des Verwaltungsgerichts und das ist dann
alles ganz schnell so läuft es ja nicht
und wenn das im in Rheinland-Pfalz nur
drei bis vier Monate dauert das
Asylverfahren ist das wirklich schnell
im Schnitt ist glaube ich in Deutschland
sieben bis acht Monate
dass Verwaltungsgerichte sind nicht
überall so schnell häufig gibt es dann
noch eine nächste Instanz und dann haben
wir ja das Problem dass selbst bei denen
die eigentlich gehen müssen
Ausreiseverbote ganz diverser Art aus
Gesundheit aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
weil und so weiter oder die Leute müssen
wirklich gehen und es gibt keinen
abschiebeverbot aber sie gehen halt
nicht und dann sehen wir ja auch wie
wahnsinnig aufwendig teuer kompliziert
die Abschiebungen sind tatsächlich die
Durchführung also wie die Bundespolizei
dann kommt und irgendwie 15 Leute
versucht abzuschieben und dann gibt es
aber dann den einen der doch nicht
abgeschoben werden darf weil das Gericht
im letzten Moment sagt der doch nicht
und dann einer der entzieht sich der
Abschiebung und so weiter also das ja
auch und so stelle ich fest bei manchen
Politiker eine Art Resignation einsetzt
weil es so schwierig ist weil es so
teuer ist und so weiter ist gar nicht
erst mit der werfe vielleicht zu
versuchen wie es notwendig wäre das
führt dazu dass man eben aus diesem
eigentlich in dieser Theorie guten
System
das Funktionalität hat dass man sagt
dass Asylverfahren läuft und danach
sozusagen endet das irgendwie in einer
in geduldung und das ist jetzt zu
pauschal gesagt ich weiß es gibt auch
die anderen Fälle
also ich war immer davon überzeugt auch
zu 15 das eine humane Flüchtlingspolitik
nur möglich ist wenn man umgekehrt
konsequent ist mit den Menschen die
nicht bei uns bleiben können und das
müssen wir auch und wir müssen auch bei
dem Thema Rückführung wieder besser
werden wir waren da auch schon mal
besser das ist wirklich es gehört
zusammen es sind nicht mehr so es sind
nicht mehr so viele Menschen die wir
zurückführen können wie damals weil
Balkan war auch eine andere Situation
aber das ist er hat auch was mit
Glaubwürdigkeit zu tun und mit der Frage
wie viel schaffen wir eigentlich
wirklich noch ja jetzt reden wir schon
über das Stimmung im Land jetzt reden
wir schon über das Ende dieses
asyl-prozesses
momentan es ist angesprochen worden
kommen eben sehr sehr viele Menschen aus
dem arabischen Raum aus der Türkei aus
Syrien Ländern und Landkreisen gehen die
guten Lösungen aus und bei den
schlechten gibt es dann tatsächlich auch
noch Unruhe dazu
500 Menschen leben im Ortskern von Upahl
in Mecklenburg ein Containerdorf für 400
geflüchtete soll hier errichtet werden
die Anwohner haben Angst wenn da 500
Asylanten sind und wir gehen alleine in
diesen kleinen Dorf mal auf der Straße
die überrennen uns doch wenn das
wirklich viele junge Männer sind die
haben Langeweile die wissen nicht wohin
es ist nichts in Unfall vor dem Kreistag
tumultartige Szenen aufgebrachte
Anwohner aber auch rechtsradikale wollen
ins Gebäude eindringen und müssen von
der Polizei in Schach gehalten werden
[Musik]
auch bei einer Bürgerversammlung im
Februar viel Frust und Ablehnung
Landrat Timo Schumann versucht die Bogen
zu glätten und fordert gleichzeitig mehr
Hilfe vom Bund
draußen das gewohnte Bild
rechtsradikale die weiter die Stimmung
anheizen
Tino Schumann ist bei uns CDU Landrat
aus
Nordwestmecklenburg Herr Schumann wollen
die Menschen in ihrem Landkreis am
liebsten gar keine Flüchtlinge haben
doch wir haben es ja gezeigt auch im
letzten Jahr wir haben über 2700
Menschen aus der Ukraine aufgenommen und
zusätzlich noch mal 460 Menschen aus
anderen Ländern also Asylbewerber
aufgenommen über 3000 Menschen in meinem
Landkreis über zwei Prozent
Bevölkerungswachstum und es war eine
große solidarische Leistung in meinem
Landkreis und ganz klar wir stellen uns
Aufgabe und jetzt regt sich Widerstand
die Frage ist ja nicht das Ob sondern
das wie das Wasser Palme auch Ansprache
zu Recht das ist die Frage die wir bei
uns im Landkreis haben die viele
landratskollegen haben und das
bundesweit
frühere Informationen mehr Transparenz
hätte das bei den Bürgern von Upahl
schon geholfen ich mache seit acht
Jahren Kommunalpolitik und bin ein
perfekter von Transparenz es war hier
nicht möglich aufgrund der
Geschwindigkeit der Reservierung dieser
Containeranlage
erklären also sie hatten nur diese
Container sind knapp sie hatten nur drei
Tage Zeit zu entscheiden ob und wie sie
diese Container erwerben und wohin sie
sie stellen muss man ja in Ruhe mal
erzählen und dann haben sie entschieden
dass die nach Opal kommen und hatten
nicht mehr ausreichend Zeit den Bürgern
dieses Ortes das mitzuteilen
zerschlagen hatte an anderen Standort
und hier sind wir in opal unser
kommunales unser Landkreis eigenes
Grundstück zurückgekommen weil es die
letzte Konsequenz war und von allen
schlechtesten Lösungen die wir auf dem
Tisch liegen hatten vor Opa die die
umsetzbar war und das schnell in der
Geschwindigkeit weil ich im Rückblick
seit Ende letzten Jahres Menschen in
Sporthallen habe asylbe habe und das ist
ja kein Zustand vor dem Hintergrund auch
dessen dass wir die Akzeptanz in der
Bevölkerung brauchen und dass die
Bewegung von Sport halt eben das
eindeutig falsche Signal so und jetzt
500 Bewohner dieses Dorfes und 400
Flüchtlinge da sagt jeder dass es gar
kein gutes Verhältnis
was antworten Sie den Menschen die ihnen
das auch so hinstellen und sagen wer
schon schön wenn es vielleicht nur 50
wären und ich bin dennoch ein
Menschenfreund die Lage hat es erfordert
ich bekomme jede Woche zwischen 20 und
30 Zuweisungen vom Land da sind im
Schnitt zwischen 80 und 120 Menschen im
Monat und ich habe keine Kapazitäten ich
habe keine Plätze mehr frei für die
Asylbewerber bei der Ukrainisch
geflüchteten hatten wir 700 Menschen im
letzten Jahr mehr aufgenommen als sie
nach Code hätte müssen wir haben es
gerne getan wir haben es gezeigt dass
wir es können aber jetzt waren die
Kapazitäten am Ende und wir brauchen
ganz dringend Platz um die Menschen auf
den Hallen zurückzunehmen und mit der
Perspektive dessen war es nur ein ein
Zeitfaktor den wir geschaffen haben dass
wir April Anfang Mai auch Upahl schon
hätten oder würde voll sein so dass wir
weitere Unterkünfte brauchen und das
schnell und deswegen war das hier mit
der Geschwindigkeit und der dramatischen
Lage die wir vor Ort haben so
erforderlich ich hätte mir auch kleinere
Unterkünfte gewünscht ganz ganz klar
aber wir brauchen hier die Ressourcen um
also die Menschen wieder die Fachkräfte
die wir angesprochen haben auch hier in
ihrer Runde gerade um das auch zu
betreuen
schnell werden ja auch solche Orte zu
pilgerarten von Extremisten
wie sehr machen die Lösungen schwieriger
für Sie die speziellen aber auch andere
im Landkreis die zeigen sich ganz klar
distanziert von diesen Personengruppen
auch der angezeigte gerade Kreistag am
26 januar haben sich eben gewisse
Personengruppen rechtsradikale und
andere das dafür genutzt und das
ausgenutzt und hier Stimmung zu machen
und das Demonstrationsrecht ist ein
hohes Gut und die Operation von ganz
klar distanziert sie haben eben gegen
die Unterkunft an sich demonstriert weil
ihm das natürlich ich in dem der
Dimension zu groß ist das ist auch dem
Kreistag klar gewesen dass es mir klar
gewesen es gab zu dem Zeitpunkt bis
heute auch keine andere Lösung wir
brauchen Opal und das nur zeitweise das
ganz klare Ziel ist Opal muss so schnell
wie möglich wieder kleiner gebaut werden
und bestmöglich auch wieder abgebaut
werden an anderen Standorten die wir bis
heute nicht haben und das ist jetzt
praktisch die Entscheidung es gibt einen
Baustopp und es gibt ein kleineres
opalcontainerdorf oder mit wie vielen
Menschen oder wissen Sie das noch gar
nicht auch die 4 Plätze genehmigt
bekommen der Bauantrag richtet sich auch
auf die 400 Plätze wir brauchen die 400
Plätze ganz ganz dringend ich habe keine
Kapazität mehr 0 in meinem Landkreis für
weitere Aufnahmen von Menschen ich habe
ein Lehrer schon von unter 2% im
Landkreis auch was in Wohnung angeht und
dass das Thema sozialer Wohnungsbau der
das Thema was wir brauchen weil wir die
Menschen nach dem Verfahren auch die 50%
bleiben dürfen müssen irgendwohin ziehen
und wo sollen sie wenn wir keine Wohnung
haben wir haben keine Sozialwohnung und
ganz ganz wenige und das ist die große
Aufgabe die der Bund ja sich auf die
Fahne geschrieben hat und die auch
endlich Geschwindigkeit oder ein Fahrt
aufnehmen muss ja schon mal ein klasse
dass wir sie heute bei uns haben und ich
marschiere zurück in die Runde und Frage
Frau Dreier und dann gleich ein Palmer
wie schnell sollen sich 400 Asylbewerber
in einem Dorf mit 500 Einwohnern so
richtig zu Hause in Deutschland füllen
ja das ist natürlich schwierig aber der
Herr Landrat hat ja dargestellt wie die
Situation ist in seinem Landkreis und
dass er die Entscheidung mit seinem
Gremium trifft das jetzt vorübergehen
einfach diese Unterkunft notwendig ist
natürlich wünscht man sich etwas anderes
dass man in dieser Größenordnung nicht
an einer Stelle so viele Flüchtlinge
unterbringen das ist immer erstmal eine
ungute Sache aber das Problem ist klar
geworden ich kann diesen Landkreis jetzt
auch nicht von hier aus beurteilen ich
glaube das letzte Statement von ihm ist
sehr sehr wichtig für uns alle wir
müssen nämlich schauen dass es
weitergeht mit dem sozialen Wohnungsbau
wir haben Wohnungsknappheit und Not ohne
ihn in ganz vielen Ballungsräumen aber
offensichtlich auch eine ländlichen
Räumen und dieses Thema voranzubringen
den Menschen werden ein bisschen weiter
hier bleiben wir brauchen ja auch
dauerhaftere Lösungen wir haben sind uns
alle einig dass wir nicht von einer
flüchtlingskrise zur nächsten können
sein wir haben weltweit einfach
Geschehnisse die uns immer wieder
herausfordern werden und da ist es doch
so dass es wichtig ist dass wir auch
permanent Lösungen brauchen die dann da
sind aber auch finanziert sind für das
Kommunen auch wirklich das Gefühl haben
können wir können auch mit dieser Lage
besser umgehen wie das im Moment eben
ist wo so viel auf einmal kommen die
Geschichte geschieht in hoffen sagt ein
Bekannter Dramaturg aus dem Osten was
macht man klugerweise in einer solchen
Situation
weil ja nicht zu erwarten steht dass es
übermorgen
Ausweichquartiere gibt für die Menschen
was haben wir gelernt aus 2015 also ich
habe gehört dass die Frau
Bundesministerin Feser da Auffassung ist
wir in den Kommunen sind schuld weil wir
ja hätten leerstehende Einrichtungen die
letzten Jahre beibehalten können da muss
ich ehrlich gesagt ist so ein Punkt wo
ich mich als Kommunalpolitiker nicht
ernst genommen fühle also immer da weiß
Frau Feser nicht wie es aussieht vor Ort
wir können da nicht über Jahre hinweg
Wohnraum leer stehen lassen während die
Leute alle hinteren nach Wohnraum suchen
und dann den wieder reaktivieren wenn
gerade der bunten hinter der Lage ist
Ordnung in der Zuwanderung zu schaffen
und deswegen ist es ehrlicherweise so
dass ich nur den Kollegen mitfühlen kann
bin froh dass es bei mir nicht so
dramatisch war unser Landkreis konnte
mir verteilen da waren großes Hotel leer
gefallen gerade dann hat man dann
ankunftszentrum einrichten können da
ging das also in der Stadt sehr viel
leichter als bei ihm aber das was er
berichtet ist berichten immer mehr
Kollegen und wir kommen in Situationen
die wir nicht meist und können wir
schaffen das Licht nicht mehr so muss
man das formulieren und dann muss man
auch damit umgehen dass der Neubau von
Sozialwohnungen der ja gerade einbricht
als zunimmt dass der viele Jahre dauern
wird also Ehrlichkeit gegenüber der
Bevölkerung zu sagen das Problem werden
die Kommunen euch nicht lösen können
dann wird die Unterbringung leider je
mehr kommen umso häufiger so sein wie
das gerade von ihnen gehört haben in
opal und die Zahl die jetzt die ersten
beiden Monate sind lässt seine Prognose
von 400.000 dieses Jahr durchaus zu
scheint nicht übertrieben zu sein
400.000 wird noch viele Opals schaffen
das sollte man im Bund erkennen und
deswegen ist auch Ordnung in der
Flüchtlingspolitik eine Forderung von
der wir nicht abgehen können wir haben
erwischt ich muss Sie um eine kurze
Antwort bitten im Grunde versucht zu
sagen was wir besser machen können im
Vergleich zu 2015 oder wenigstens anders
machen können in der jetzigen Situation
ist es schwer weil ja es wirklich
überall fehlt also nicht nur an Menschen
die solche Einrichtungen dann auch
schützen und betreuen sondern ihr
offensichtlich auch an Material und der
Fähigkeit dann schnell für Wohnraum zu
sorgen was würden Sie erstes tun wenn
sie könnten und zwar sofort
das umsetzen was die Ministerpräsidentin
Ministerpräsidenten heute beschlossen
haben Ordnung und Humanität zusammen
denken dass es ja schon mehrfach gesagt
worden
Verfahren beschleunigen Standards
absenken all diese Dinge sind jetzt
nötig darüber müssen wir mit der
Bundesregierung sehr ernsthaft sprechen
viele Menschen werden bleiben und
deswegen brauchen wir bessere Antworten
am 10.05 allerspätestens und vor wow die
letzte Frage an Sie wir schaffen das
oder schaffen wir das nicht
muss ich jetzt in einem Satz Antworten
also ich würde sagen wir schaffen das
nur wenn Konsequenzen gezogen werden in
den verschiedenen Punkten die wir heute
angesprochen haben und wenn es
jedenfalls nicht sozusagen so weiter
läuft und deswegen ist es gut dass es
für den 10 Mai jetzt ein Treffen mit dem
Bundeskanzler gibt dass diese
verschiedenen Ebenen noch besser
verzahnt werden und das Finanzierung
bereitgestellt wird und auch
Flüchtlingspolitik ist auch immer
Kommunikation also Kommunikation nach
innen und auch nach außen um zu sagen
und zu begrenzen auch ja wir haben ein
Problem ich darf mich als ich bedanken
an dieser Stelle für diese Sendung heute
Abend auch nach Düsseldorf ein
herzlicher Dank und wir geben sofort zu
Markus Lanz der heute unter anderem
Motiv zu Gast hat und wir sehen uns wenn
Sie mögen gleiche Stelle gleiche Welle
am nächsten Donnerstag wieder vielen
Dank kommen Sie gut durch die Nacht
danke schön
[Musik]